Chris Haynes of ESPN he's an NBA
reporter for ESPN has been on the show
multiple times glad app back here how
are you Chris
I'm fine okay so what can you tell me is
it is it really looking like LeBrons
going to the Lakers best you can tell
from all your sources Chris as a right
now I say you know people I've been
talking to she sounds like it's 50/50 as
a right now as a potential Cleveland if
you would ask me so week ago I would I
would lean heavily towards the Lakers
but just the way I see it the way it's
been explained to me is that the brown
would like to you know stay in Cleveland
keep his family there but the problem is
Cleveland is going to have a difficult
time trying to bring their players that
you know can help him continue to
continue to Championships because LeBron
he's not satisfied at getting there you
know I think we've seen by his talent
alone today you can take marginal talent
to the finals and ease the conference
but you know he doesn't want to keep
going and keep getting the date about it
go to the state warriors so that's going
to be the dilemma was Cleveland and with
the Lakers I think even if he were like
I know the pawns were staying and I'm
I'm here in Paul George as well sounds
like he's leaning towards backward
signing with OKC
I actually before that probably about
two months ago but even if a Braun did
go to LA by himself think that mindset
is and I think it is that LA being such
an attractive market and with assets
that it would take any time at all for
him to get their talent over there so
you know as a right now I think it's
5050 but obviously things will change in
a matter of hours of course I'm
absolutely Chris Haynes here in the Rich
Eisen show let's dig into the Paul
George a little bit more two months ago
you were hearing what what appears to be
the case again appears to be how do we
get Paul George going from I'm going to
LA essentially get me out of here in
Indiana I understand you say things to
maybe get out of situation you don't
want to be in and here he has a chance
to come to LA and potentially team up
with LeBron James
he might not take it is that a money
thing walk me through the thought
process here Chris no I wouldn't I
wouldn't even say it's a money thing I'm
you know I went to me and Paul George
actually went to school to get our final
state we had a classic era so I know I'm
pretty well like she doesn't like to he
doesn't like to reject people he doesn't
want to come off as as he's burnin a
team organization she's a real loyal guy
and I know that probably sounds funny
being that we've heard for the last
couple years I boarded the boat Indiana
called the Lakers but you know what OKC
did you know basically they had a
recruiting ceremony for him the whole
year already and he did he doesn't want
to come off as he you know a one-year
rental and check off the leaves he knows
how how much was a Westbrook is that
juncture it is career yeah yeah actually
it's gotten worse over the last couple
seconds but keep going all right now you
got hanging on your every word you're
saying okay so that's the type of guy he
is in and I will add this that you know
he's doing this you know they're special
with us ESPN so what kind of document
his on process to free agency I have a
hard time believing that he will leave
OKC knowing Paul know how it is I have a
hard time believing he would leave OKC
and do it while here in this you know
kind of behind the scenes documentary
and so I just don't
it just doesn't point to him Bolton on
top of what we've been hearing over the
last couple of us anyway so that's why
you know that's why you know if you ask
Mike that's why I say you know I'm I
thinking is that he's going to stay well
I mean let's let's dig into this even
further then cuz look I mean I've met
Kevin Durant on a couple of occasions
that's it but just reading about him and
having met him on those couple of
occasions he's a nice guy too
who doesn't want to be seen like
spurning anybody who definitely has a
sensitive side from what he has say said
about what has been said about him since
he left Oklahoma City burn
accounts as well well it will evidence
that and he's won MVP twice in a row of
the finals so when it's all said and
done I think that that might you know
put a band-aid over any hurt feelings
Paul George doesn't see that and maybe
want that with LeBron in his hometown he
wouldn't be enticed by that no I think
you have a point there I think just
between Kevin Durant and Paul George
that Durant played there for what nine
years eight or nine years OKC so it was
it was a situation where I was building
it up where he said okay I'm not getting
to where I want to get at my career you
know the proper pieces or the right
style of play hasn't been playing in
order for us to get to that next step so
I think that's why I wouldn't say it was
easier for him but you know it was a
compilation of days with Paul George has
been one season there and I'm pretty
sure okay OKC is telling him okay let's
build let's build upon this let's let's
do we need to do you know Carmelo
Anthony the way they play him last year
was allowing him to be in the spot
lineup just I think a woman are going
with some modification to say so pause
or look we're going to different we're
gonna make you more of a straighter
point let's see what we should go so I
think that's attractive and appealing to
Paul and I'm not saying he was fine
there long term but I definitely think
the by said that he will be back in okay
okay
Chris Haynes of ESPN joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show and you've been
locked in with the Warriors for a couple
of years now with the world wide leader
and from my days at ESPN I I know the
sensitivities to this so I asked it with
the utmost of respect I don't want you
to comment on and other colleagues of
yours reporting or refute it or if you
can confirm it that'd be great
is it true that LeBron texted Kevin
Durant and said hey let's team up and
Staples together is that true
he took a shot Andy I have not I have
not been able to confirm that I've
actually actually text KD he said you
know he said that's not true and I you
know I spoke with LeBron camp
they said they said the same thing but
that's not you know hey that's not to
say my guy Stephen a was wrong in that
and you know we get information from all
type of area so I'm not sure I mean it
doesn't sound outlandish I will say that
he can't blame her for shooting a shot
if that's the way it's going right now I
mean man and then the Kawai of it all -
I mean I can't get enough of a Chris I
really can it's so dramatic with such
big-name players and how it could
rearrange chess pieces the question is
though is is whenever everything drops
knowing the Warriors as you do and how
good they are and what goes on in their
locker room do you think that when the
dust settles over the next few weeks we
will have an entity somewhere in the NBA
that can be thrown the Warriors ooh you
know what I always say this man I truly
believe I know I probably get beat up
for saying this god I truly believe this
Chris Paul was healthy and being able to
play in those last couple of games man
probably woulda got him I really do I
think you still woulda got go to the
stage and if you look at this summer you
mentioned all the chess pieces all the
dominoes have to fall into place in
order to create create a you know a semi
dynasty there enough or our super team
excuse me in LA the the core Islander
factly rich like you know you know we're
here now these people that you know
these teams that who are crying about
koala let me say this but from what
happened what was explained to me you
know you talk about Boston growing like
kawaii is not resigning long time at
Boston that is not the case so if you
know I think that's one of the main
reasons why I Boston is not throwing the
total package at said that sorry that's
just not a destination uh for Kauai you
know that's just not something easy to
treat with it's the to LA chains
it's the Lakers and his clippers and
Allah has been made off the Lakers but
he wants to play home you know he's from
San Diego area he wants to play off and
be happy was what it was told so I you
know if that if they can if the Lakers
can pull that off
that they can get if they can get LeBron
James over there and then you know then
that's what I think you know Paul's your
if he hasn't made a decision by the end
after that I didn't ask about the mic
and start to change
you know clans can start the waiver and
you know it like I say it's just a
domino effect but we just don't know
which Domino's want to fall first
because obviously I think all has to
fall in order for this whole free agency
landscape is just opened up well then I
guess I'll ask you the the last same
last question as I asked Brian Wynn
horse on this subject what's the
timeframe here because if LeBron wants
to play with Kawhi and I'm assuming
that's that's that he would love to do
then he needs to hold off on signing to
keep the pressure on the Lakers and the
Spurs to make a deal to go get him but
he also doesn't want to come and play
with Kawhi if the rest of the cupboard
is totally bare if it's only Lonzo left
because Popovich wants no piece of the
Paul family well how do you see this all
playing out Paul George hanging back to
see if he wants to be the third man in
if that's entirely possible under the
cap etc what do you think about this all
plays out Chris look I think it's four I
don't know if LeBron is gonna go this
route but I obviously consider his best
interest to hold out to wait to see what
happens but I was told from you know
from Paul George's camp sacralized camp
from the bronze chapter that they're all
going to do independently what's best
for them and if they're not going to
wait for anybody else and you know I
know there's been a lot of talk about
people saying that those three guys have
been talking to communicating and you
know almost all three sides will say
that's inaccurate but I find that hard
to believe that they haven't spoke you
know these are three biggest free agents
on the market well you know collide
potentially be a swap I have a hard time
believing that but look that's what
that's what they said they're going to
do so as a right now you know we're
under my said believe that LeBron is
going to make that decision relatively
soon I'm just not sure if Kawhi will be
at Whoopie has switch teams at that
point Chris great stuff Thanks
chat will chat down the line you got
that set set that's Chris being so rich
eysan show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience